shorthand and voice which is not
presently included in statute so that
both methods are recognized as certified
court reporters
the committee report has been sent to
all members of the committee and should
be available on our website to members
of the public should this not be found
in our public website
please inform me and I will Rectify this
problem
part number one part B
a task force on family law pursuant to
chapter 250 laws of 2002 as amended by
chapter 257 laws of 2003 comprised House
and Senate Judiciary Committee members a
house children and family law Committee
Member with further one is an alternate
representatives of Guardians at Litem
judge in Family Division the commission
on the status of men
the commission on the status of women
a psychologist members of the bar and
other organizations they were on the
task force interestingly representatives
of numbers of these groups have already
made presentations or will be making
presentations before us they are not
members of the committee this time they
an interim report under the name of Nina
C Gardner was presented on October 30 of
2003 in a fuller report under the same
name on November 1st
2004. both of these reports contain
numerous recommendations
these reports have been sent to all
members of the committee and should be
available on our website to members of
the public should any of these not be
found in our public website please
inform me and I will seek to rectify
number two second iteration Ten Years
Later in 2012 there was a house
committee on the redress of grievances
because I spoke of this committee at
some length last week I will give only a
Bare Bones comment now there was a
report from representative Paul
ingridson chair there was an additional
report originally published in the house
Journal of March 21
2012. finally there exists a legal
analysis by The Honorable Charles G
Douglas III then house legal counsel
dated April 28 2015.
these three items have been sent to all
members of the committee and should be
available on our website to members of
the public should any of these three
reports not be found in our public
website please inform me and I will seek
to rectify this problem now I am calling
attention to all of these previous
iterations for the following reasons
first it will be very helpful for
committee members to read these reports
both now and periodically as we progress
with our work
second it will demonstrate
that because of the complexities of the
law
the question of the degree to which
Arbiters should have discretion and the
fact that although all divorce custody
alimony and child support cases have
things in common each case is unique
so a
one-size-fits-all law rule or protocol
may be somewhat difficult to craft
notice how the previous committees
wrestled with all of this as we will be
wrestling
and third reason for calling attention
to these past reports
that while each iteration of looking at
the court had similarities to each of
the others each committee approached and
is approaching the matter somewhat
differently
this diversity of style and methodology
to me is helpful it's a good thing
I'm glad we're all looking at this in
different ways therefore one committee
does not really comprise the entire body
even of present investigation we have
these other things as precedents that
inform us
second introductory matter of today
emails text letters phone calls
as the existence of this committee
becomes more widely known
communication with either me as the
chairman or with all of us the committee
is increasing
I much appreciate those who understand
and cooperate with the ground rules I've
laid down for conveying of information
to us
these people realize as much as they
would like a do-over on their trial or a
listening ear that commiserates
we if we are to accomplish our goals
need information provided in a certain
way
I especially appreciate those who
understand it and by the way those who
filled out pink cards and now said can I
be put off another week I don't think
I'm ready to do it in the format you
wish thank you that gives what you say
and I also appreciate all the thank yous
that are coming already that is
comforting as we do our work
but because of the growing volume of
communication
and the fact that everyone on our
committee has other things to do in the
legislature at home and for some of us
at our day job or jobs
we can devote only so much time to the
communication sent to us
for me and I know in talking with some
of you on the committee that means
prioritizing
what comes to us
speaking for myself top priority is
communication from someone who hasn't
communicated with us before or who has
done it but only once
what those folks send is new information
or else
in a follow-up communication back from
us clarification is made to a question
about more information
it also means an increase increasing
unlikelihood
of reading
everything
especially Communications from the hands
full of people who seek to address US
frequently we've heard you
sometimes these communications come
every day or two
and have demonstrated those people
cannot or will not adhere to sticking to
the kinds of things we choose to hear
my time devoted to this special
committee is insufficient to attend to
lectures on how this committee is doing
our job wrongly
and it is insufficient to attend to
extremely long reviews of entire cases
including personal attacks I don't have
the time for that
perhaps there may be someday another
committee that works differently
and would welcome all of these things
but this is not that committee
and then finally the third introductory
matter I have been asked to read every
week the document entitled notice and
disclaimer so here goes again
the special committee on the Family
Division of the Circuit Court was formed
to investigate allegations of
irregularities including failure to
follow or enforce statutes unwarranted
waiver of or failure to follow court
rules delay in rendering decisions
denial of due process and other
procedural issues
the committee will conduct hearings
relative to the process of the Family
Division of the circuit court and may
make recommendations for future
legislation
the purpose of the committee is to
discover areas where changes in
procedures or changes in law regarding
the Family Division of the Circuit Court
might be made the purpose of this
special committee
is not to retry the cases of citizens
who disagree with the outcome of
litigation
members of the public will be given
opportunity to testify and present
information to the committee because of
the numbers of people who may wish to
testify there may be a time limit
imposed on each person testifying
which is permissible under house rule
100.
appropriate subject matter for Testimony
will be limited to specific instances of
where there seem to be irregularities in
process procedure or adherence to rules
and statutes
those testifying about subject matter
related to a court case or who submit
documentation related to a court case
should know that both of these will be
made part of the public record therefore
subject matter that is either
confidential or may be under seal should
not be discussed or submitted to the
committee as disclosure of such matters
would be a violation of Statute or court
order
and let me add as I did last time the
committee has no way of knowing
when a person is testifying whether that
person is violating these things or not
the burden in maybe any future
punishment of violating is solely on you
and not on the committee so you'll have
to censor yourself
and then finally the committee reserves
the right not to accept written or oral
testimony or materials
that would in its judgment violate all
the foregoing
so with that in mind we continue
listening to folks from various
organizations and as I pointed out 20
years ago they were actually part of the
committee this time I chose not to do it
that way but instead invite them to come
and make a presentation
and in my schedule I have down Office of
the child advocate
so with that person or persons please
um
I'm looking at my scheduler
well okay that's not what I have it is
um
there is no one else scheduled for today
is that correct um Christina
this
all right yeah sure we've got a few
people who are
um who have turned in some pink cards
um
all right the chair recognizes Dale
Savoy
who wonderfully has presented all the
specific information that we have
requested on the back of the very same
I I tried to be accommodating well you
know
so and actually I you know I also uh
said that I would get you the
information in terms of uh uh
all the statistics on fatherless homes
I'm still working on that I didn't
realize it that you were going to be
doing these meetings every week so uh I
don't have that as of yet but I I do
have the information okay you got five
minutes for your presentation and when
you're finished with that
um we will be archiving your card and
and so on so when more information comes
to us we can attach that perfect so I
just wanted to clarify
um
when I mentioned my views for for uh
granting my my children's Mother uh
custody
um and limiting my my visitation to them
um
that was based on uh oral testimony that
that she had provided at the time the
time in the judge responded to but uh in
the actual uh final order if I may read
uh there were some suggestions by the
Father the parties could follow a
nesting agreement which is we would we
would switch off the kids would stay in
the house we would switch off which
seems reasonable to me at the time Court
does not find this proposal appropriate
there has been tension between the
parties in the past with Father
exhibited behavior that described as
Intense or even
controlling during the marriage
no examples given there was not that
there was nothing that would exhibit
that other than my uh intensity in the
courtroom at the suggestion that I
should have my kids taken away from me
and I think the Judge actually used that
and that's where that's coming from and
how she Justified that
and goes on to say
there have been times where this
intensity was also visited upon the
children a manner of commuting to them
example telling the oldest daughter
which they're not mentioning she was an
adult at the time that she needed to get
her together uh
I think most people would agree that's
that's hardly an intense situation where
it would be considered child abuse and
oh by the way we were alone and my other
children were not in proximity at the
time that event occurred
um she also goes on to reference their
involvement by the police in the past uh
that was an incident where uh my my one
of my children was having an issue in
school with they were making decisions
about it and I wanted to be a party to
the that process while my ex did not
agree with that and upon my immediate
exiting of her presence she called the
police on me and she actually used that
as leverage in that in that hearing
and the judge requested I don't know if
the judge saw the footage of of that
interaction because the the police had
cameras and I think you would find that
what you would see mostly in that is is
my uh
a high degree of sadness in that I was
not able to
participate in these kinds of decisions
in my kids lives
and that did that did affect my kids as
they got older going through it's you
know this this goes into the part where
removing fathers from these situations
and it affected my own kids is really
negative on kids
and that needs to be driven home to the
court and
listening to your your conversation of
the the prior meeting to the one that I
was able to attend you talked about
uh either laws being broken or rules
being violated in in the courtroom well
I'm not sure that in this case that any
law or rules was violated the courts
right now are the judges are basically
given a blanket coverage under best
interest of the children and under best
interests of the children the judge
feels for whatever reason it's in the
there's little there's little you can do
under the law
in order to
to hold the judge accountable for any
kind of
inappropriate decision making
because you're really up to it's up to
the judge
the word I'm looking for uh
discretion they are given a tremendous
amount of description under best
interest of the children
in terms of being able to make these
kinds of decisions
so I'm not sure how effective if you're
limited to law breaking or rule breaking
how effective can this panel possibly be
if that's if you're under this situation
I'd be curious to get a response from
from this Committee in terms of how
outside of rules and law breaking
what would you be able to do
anyone on the committee have a question
the
representative law
thank you Mr chairman uh
thank you Mr Savoy uh now you spoke of
your adult daughter and and what are the
how many children and what were their
ages I have four kids at that time so
they they're roughly two years apart so
my youngest would have been um
follow up there were three there were
three other children that were not
adults and their age were
um so that would have been uh 16 14 and
12 roughly okay great thank you
representative Smith Vice chairman Vice
chair Smith well thank you uh I'm here
here I am
thank you for um taking my question
um
you understand that we are not an
appellate court
yes uh thank you for for acknowledging
that what we are trying to do is
determine what it would be appropriate
for the legislative branch to do
um in terms of identifying difficulties
and finding uh ways to address those
difficulties
ever uh
write or contact the judicial conduct
committee
uh so
most of my
when I was uh going through this whole
trial most of my interaction was was my
peers and
friends family that have gone through
this process and many of them have tried
to do that and almost to a person
anybody that did do that anybody I
communicated felt that it was completely
useless
and when you think about hey the judges
have
such a degree of discretion with in
terms of of
um
best interest of the children how can
you possibly uh affect any kind of
change
I mean just this example alone the judge
decided based on my conduct in the
courtroom that I was an intense person
an overly intense person and not
justified her limiting my access to my
children
and and I think if you played that audio
footage to to the general public they
would agree that that makes no sense
a father
showing intensity for wanting to
participate in their kids life it would
normally be a good thing
but in a court setting for whatever
reason they view that as a negative
they want you to go into that courtroom
be very restrained
matter of fact and bring no emotion into
it at all well that's I got to tell you
if personally that's very difficult to
do
so if I go before the the you know this
committee what would I possibly be able
to say or do
that would have any kind of effective
anything that they could work on the
judge has discretion
for
best interest of the children when you
read through the through the family
courts all right thank you very much for
answering my question thank you
representative Macbeth
thank you I'm Mr chairman and thank you
Mr Savoy for taking my question
um in your criticism of the Court's
order
um I'm not clear that I have your
language correctly but I think you said
they Court based its rejection of the
nesting proposal that you had based on
your controlling and aggressive behavior
uh intense Behavior well in combination
with we're going through a divorce so
there's contention there between okay so
so my question is generally the court
made a conclusion and it backed it up by
those observations so is your in terms
of what they wrote I can't speak to what
she felt she could write and and was
justifiable when you look at the final
order what she did wrote had to do with
uh my intensity if you will
so my question is is your testimony that
there was not any evidence in the record
that you did have the aggressive or
intense Behavior or you wanted the judge
to provide examples of what that type of
testimony was so it's at best you could
say it was hearsay from from my ex
there was nothing it was basically just
he's intense
and there was nothing there was no
examples given other than
the conversation I had with my oldest
daughter that was the only example given
and if that's the worst thing that I
have done
I would be an exemplary father
just follow up so I know you didn't have
an attorney but you were you are you
aware I don't know of filing Motions
like a motion for clarification or
motion for reconsideration or finding a
fact and rulings of law that would have
clarified that I did provide
um my case number on the on the pin card
so if you look at that I did try
multiple occasions um for one thing if
if it's not if your your emotions are
not written the way the court
likes or deems appropriate for that
emotion so if I could just dismissed on
that alone because what I was just
specifically because we're looking at um
you know problems or irregular irregular
irregularities yeah process so you
criticize the court order and and said
that you didn't think the basis of their
conclusion was correct so I'm just
asking for that specific court order did
you file any pleading that would have
clarified or confirmed your you know
feeling like the court had been
arbitrary in that ruling well certainly
not at the time no I felt you know I I
just
I don't want to say assume but I
concluded based on the the information
provided that in the absence of other
testimony or or any real
um
cases or scenarios where you would
consider that to be intense or you know
anything in the realm of abusive uh
none of that was presented
so for me
trying to uh
so when you get when you're given uh the
case you're you're basically assigned to
a specific Judge and you're with that
judge until this thing concludes I am
still going through with this judge so
thank you so you've answered it you did
in other aspects of it but not
specifically having to do with this
thank you thank you
um
any other questions uh representative
ball
thank you chairman Pearson um could you
tell me if there was anyone in the
courthouse who was there to help you
fill out any paperworks or help direct
you through the process
thank you you had no lawyer you were
litigant pro se
okay was your wife uh she had she had a
lawyer yes
okay because sometimes we hear judges
bend over backwards to help litigan's
Pro Se especially when the other party
has legal counsel uh that actually
probably that did happen to an extent at
the beginning of of the this whole thing
where I had a trial I actually told I
actually asked the judge the fact that I
don't have the the fact that I don't
have a lawyer will it impact the overall
outcome of this thing and I you know if
you get the Oriole test the or the oral
recording of that those hearings you'll
hear that where I actually
Express concern about that to the judge
and the judge felt at the time that it
it would not impact her overall view
okay thank you and and this is a leading
question but I think it actually is more
clarifying what I thought I heard lead
away
I won't have to declare you a hostile
witness to do this it's my committee
okay
um
is it your testimony that you believe
your wife made numbers of accusations
against you on various things that were
accepted but did not have proof of those
allegations uh
yes from my perspective she didn't
actually she didn't actually have to
they go in knowing her attorney I'm sure
absolutely made clear to her all we got
to do is basically show any kind of
issue of any kind you don't have to
really in terms of the oral all she did
was say I'm afraid and she was shedding
some a little bit of tears and that was
all it took
to be honest with you okay good and
that's helpful yeah so
and and when you
when you talk to other individuals in
terms of having gone through this
as well they will tell you a very
similar story they don't they don't
really have to provide much in the way
the the court system is set up
inherently biased towards mother getting
the kids and they're going to make sure
that that is going to be the outcome
okay good thank you that's all I need
for an answer
um do we have anyone else
thank you thank you for your testimony
um and if I could speak to msdaya I
don't know if I've already asked you to
do this but if I didn't I am now and if
not I'm patient some states I have been
reading extensively in law books on
family law
uh some states seem to have a built-in
um leaning I I won't use the word bias
it's a loaded word but leaning towards
moms get the kids that's the default
position almost automatically other
states don't seem to have that
and have a more it could go either way
mentality
um I'm wondering if you could do a
little bit of research to find out a
what New Hampshire is on paper because I
think I know what it may be in practice
and what a handful of other states might
do that could inform New Hampshire
because if it's for the benefit of the
kids
that's begs multiple questions the
answer to which one of those questions
is maybe it isn't automatic default to
one parent or the other so if you could
take that liberal arts question and then
turn it into real language and do some
research I'd appreciate that thank you
so much and now the chair recognizes a
presentation
[Music]
I'm a little surprised I guess by
um
the question that you just asked because
my experience limited on children and
family law
but also on Judiciary is that
are in our rsas and I would believe in
our um
one would hope in the training uh that
new judges experience and I fear that by
you asking the question that the way
that you did without our hearing
from the courts for example and others
you might have given an impression that
I don't think is accurate of you
prejudging
that situation and so I wonder if we
might back off a little bit on that
um
on that directive that you just gave to
our wonderful staff people given part of
the charge to the committee is to
investigate allegations this is one of
the allegations that I've been hearing
for years
it may prove to be unfounded I'm not
prejudicing prejudicing
the outcome of my researchers
research good I'm just raising the
question thank you very much and I could
well be informed of all of the things of
which you speak and would love to to be
thank you but thank you for raising that
appreciate that
and now we have a presentation from the
good morning Cassandra Sanchez child
advocate for the State of New Hampshire
and I have with me today
attorney Lisa massio I'm the new
associate child advocate
could you spell your name please for
everyone
sure Lissa is
l-i-s-s-a last name massio m-a-s-c-i-o
good morning so I am here today to
present on the office of the child
advocate in our overlap with the courts
it is quite important to note as many of
you may know we are independent
oversight agency over executive branch
child serving agencies which includes
dcyf and DHHS as well as the provider
agencies that contract with them
then I can lead into what our
limitations are because I would like to
make it very clear for this room we do
have limitations in our oversight we do
not have oversight over the courts we do
not have oversight over Casa and we do
not have oversight over gals although we
do interact with these entities on a
regular basis particularly in our
oversight role in looking at dcyf cases
we do not have the ability to make
recommendations or review the work of
those entities
rather we work closely with them in
trying to partner and educate those
entities so what I can share is that
the office has spent time building
relationships with a judicial system so
we attend regular judges trainings
offering information about the office as
well as trends that we see in the office
that impact the children of New
Hampshire
we also participate on the model Court
committee where again we have the
opportunity to share Trends and to work
and influencing the courts and making
positive progress that's going to focus
on the best interests of children
we are a partner in that we do not have
the oversight or review of that
committee either
and with the Casas and gals we work to
partner with them to offer trainings to
those entities much like the trainings
that we offer to the judges
my office does receive complaints in
regards to court issues parental divorce
cases
and because we do not have jurisdiction
we are not able to offer
much support and advice from the office
we may refer out to another entity or we
will have to share that it is not our
jurisdiction therefore we cannot assist
them on that case
we do not have a great data system
that's able to for us we try to go back
and look in our data system to find how
many of these we receive per year our
system is not ideal for analyzing that
kind of data so we were not able to pull
in the few that we were able to look
closely on some case examples I can
highlight some of the examples that we
have heard in regards to issues with the
court the parents have called in but
again these are not cases that we have
provided any guidance or review of
and so when those that we did Paul we
had a number of them that were ongoing
divorce or parenting cases
some of which included dcyf
where either one parent or the other was
calling into Central intake calling
allegations in against the other parents
we've had a number of cases that have
had that issue we will inform them on
the dcyf process and what it means to
have an open assessment and have them
entering the home and reviewing the home
but that's education is the minimal that
we will offer on those cases
we have also had some with complaints
about gals where parents have shared
that they feel one parent is favored
with the gal over another
um some even providing at the call in
providing documentation either emails or
some other documentation they may have
with the gals where there's information
that agal may have gone to one family
home to assess that home not the other
constant communication with one parent
not necessarily the other
and those that we have seen there's we
have not seen a preference of
a mother over a father we have heard
both sets
pretty equally
and again we are counseling them out on
those ones educating whenever possible
sending them to the correct entities for
complaints if they do have complaints
against the gals or the judge judges
decision we send them to the correct
what I can share that we are aware of
and have reviewed quite thoroughly and
many of you may be aware of as well is
the Massachusetts OCA had an opportunity
to do a report on Harmony Montgomery
case and looking at the concerns that
that arose in Massachusetts before
Harmony came to New Hampshire and one
aspect that they did highlight was the
issue with
the the judge sending the child across
state lines without full information
about the child's needs and and what
would truly be in the child's best
interest and feeling that in that case
specifically the lack of judicial
oversight and oversight over some of the
attorneys and
um in that case I believe there was not
a casa but gal so the oversight over
those entities they felt was lacking and
that is something that we have discussed
with them and and we continue to explore
but again it's not with currently within
our jurisdiction and speaking to our our
partners in Massachusetts they currently
have a similar like Committee in which
they're going to be further exploring
that issue and how they can either
stretch oversight or how there can be
some processes in place to ensure this
doesn't happen to children in the future
could you suspend for the member to ask
a question absolute thank you I've just
but my understanding is that that was
the Massachusetts court system it was
not the New Hampshire court system
correct what it does highlight for us is
a question about the oversight of Courts
and those proceedings not that we've
made any specific recommendations to New
Hampshire but something that in
reviewing such a high profile case it's
important for our office to look at the
recommendations that they had coming out
of that report and one of the large
recommendations they had was to look at
their judicial system
thank you yes you may continue thank you
absolutely
um so I've also noticed in my time and I
believe I heard the last time when
director ribsom spoke
um on behalf of dcyf in this Arena here
um there was a lot of talk about
trainings for parents attorneys and that
is something that I have engaged in
conversations with others especially in
regards to the model Court committee and
really talking about what training do
parent attorneys get and there is
agreement by many folks that engage in
that committee that we do need more
skilled attorneys available for parents
so I would agree with director ribson on
that recommendation that attorneys that
have a specialty in the family court
issues in understanding child abuse and
neglect laws specifically as well as
some understanding in Psychology and
children's best interests would be ideal
so really
finding a way in which we can build up a
pool of attorneys that can do this work
and then provide extensive training to
that group of attorneys so they can best
support their clients in those cases
it's this wonderful idea progressed to
an outline or a proposal yet
because it's a wonderful idea not yet no
it's coming though right I hope so I
haven't been having a lot of discussions
about it so I do hope so yes thank you
and I recognize another aspect that he
that director ribson spoke about when he
was here before the group that I have
had experience working with so I did
want to share my personal experience
working with this model
much like New Jersey Massachusetts had a
model where some of the public
defender's offices would have a social
worker on staff
and that social worker would work to
support the parent would work with the
agency and really understanding what
change they were looking for from the
parent and then ensuring whatever
providers or treatment recommendations
were going to be made were not only a
good fit for the parent but we're also
going to meet the needs of the agency
and so they were a great neutral party
in between to help tie the case together
and in my experience I would see cases
Move Along more quickly because parents
were willing to take the advice of a
neutral social worker and their
recommendations rather than an agency
where there's that very complex
relationship what a great idea how far
is this towards a proposal
again the same space as the other it's
it's in discussions at this point not a
proposal um we do understand in those
that have discussed these options that
it will take funding because it will
require specific staff in place
um and specifically when talking about
social workers in these positions we
have a shortage of social workers in
other places in New Hampshire and so we
have to be very mindful of anything that
is going to be a proposal to be built
out that the staff will be available
first so that we are not pulling from
our other mental health supports in the
community
remind me not to give you the address of
we're all looking for helpers I know
and another aspect that is is I just
wanted to bring it to the attention of
this committee that we have heard is
becoming more complicated
over the recent year or so
is that the courts have been abled
through the Superior Court are now able
to provide Guardians to children that
are in dcyf custody
and but the Guardians aren't necessarily
the placement option and so we've heard
a handful of calls about that issue
because the Guardians are attempting to
work with the agency but in a different
role because they are not the person
who's been found to be abusive and
neglectable of the child and then the
courts don't know how much access to
give these Guardians and so we hear that
they are often sent
back and forth between different courts
the court that gave them the
Guardianship and the judge over that
ruling and then the dcyf court where
they are a party to the case but then
are being told that they're limited
while the other judge is telling them
they are the guardian and they have
right to certain information so this is
something that's new in New Hampshire
and something just to be aware of that
there is the option for there to be a
guardian but also children to be removed
from their biological parents or their
yes representative Macbeth I just
wondered if um the child advocate would
clarify for everyone the difference
between a guardian and a guardian ad
litem yes thank you yes so the guardian
is it's typically a relative or a family
friend who arrives at court and is
presenting to the court that the child
does not have a parent caregiver and is
looking to take over the parent
caregiver role and so they are in some
way linked to the child and they are
able through this court guardianship
they are able to request records and
make decisions on behalf of the children
typically when we think of guardian we
would think of somebody who goes to the
court gets the guardianship of the child
and the child resides in their home and
so it's very similar the difference now
is that they're allowed to be Guardian
without the child
living in their home and on those cases
there is still a guardian at Litem who
is assigned to meet with a child family
system and bring forth to the court what
is in the best interest of that child
representative Smith
thank you in the in the example that you
just gave us
um
with two different judges and two
different courts are each of those
judges in the family court
yes but they could be different areas
because the Guardian could be going to
one court and the dcyf is going to
another court because of where the
parent is residing at the time that
they're going into court sometimes they
can be different judges in the same
court
follow-up if I could just follow up so
that this is
to me
an example of
um an obvious
um
area to consider for recommendations
about what the family court
might consider doing in order to
better meet the needs of the citizens of
the state and that would be coordination
in that case yes yes I mean here similar
in some of the parenting or divorce
cases where they may become dcyf
involved while they already have this
other case and process and then a family
is sent to one court or judge to deal
with their dcyf case and another court
or judge to manage the parenting plan
and divorce parenting decisions and so I
do believe that taking a look at that
and if there is a way to incorporate if
there is already a parent in case or
divorce case open and it is a similar
judge to hear the dcyf case it would
reduce the
missing information going back and forth
between the courts and reduce the amount
of times that the families have to go to
courts because they could have court in
the same week for two different types of
hearings if I could follow you may thank
you so
would there be any benefit
to the family court having a policy
of
uh one family one judge
yes I do believe that would benefit the
family as well as the children
specifically
um really having a good understanding
especially when we're talking about
abuse and neglect being looked at in the
courts if that is not understood by a
court that is putting into place
parenting plans we worry about putting
children in at-risk situations because
that Court does not hold the same
information that the other court holds
around the abuse and neglect
procedural things to the clerks this
could be something to be noted as a
point it already is thank you if I may
have been having having worked as an
attorney in both of these Arenas I was a
dcyf prosecutor and I also worked in the
private family law sector for quite a
long time
they have that policy but essentially
family court is two completely separate
courts the dcyf realm and then the
parenting realm so each of those
different Realms do have that policy I
believe Mr Savoy just testified as well
in a divorce case you typically are
assigned one judge the same judge stays
with you through your whole parenting
divorce case same thing happens in dcyf
cases it is the one judge who is
handling a dcyf case again for that
continuity but even though they're both
under the guise of the family court they
are separate courts so you can have one
family that has a one judge parenting
case one judge dcyf case and it is very
confusing
um uh dcyf judge will typically
um maybe enter a temporary parenting
order in order to close a dcyf case but
then yes the whole thing goes back to
some other judge thank you very much for
that if I could you are telling us the
way things are
what we are interested in is the way
things should be
um which isn't necessarily it might be
but isn't necessarily the way things are
so you've helped to clarify the way
things are
to make sure that the way things end up
being is the best possible way in the
interests of all the citizens of the
states so and we have noted this now on
what will be a list of discussion topics
when we get the various slices of cases
from various people and put them in
their appropriate folders and then open
the folders one at a time this will be
one we will open we will invite people
from both aspects of family court to be
here and a couple of other folks and
we'll just chew into it to see if we
want to make recommendations whether to
keep what we have or make a change and
just to throw another Wrinkle In if
there is a domestic violence situation
layered over on top that is potentially
another judge in court Who's involved
representative Macbeth thank you and
thank you for taking my question
um so this is it's my understanding
right now that the judges that would
have these individual cases in the silos
the protocols don't allow them to reach
out and talk to each other correct so it
would have to take the party that may
not have an attorney to move to join
those cases so the protocol or the
recommendation would be looking at that
the judges themselves through whatever
kind of um you know computerizing
looking up families and trying to make
connections they themselves would be
able to connect and try to work out who
should be handling what part of the case
or the entire case is that kind of a
recommendation we're looking for or is
that something that we need to ask the
judicial I would ask the judicial for my
recollection the judges can certainly
see all of the cases in the court system
I don't believe they're prohibited from
communicating but I don't know how
regularly happens I would defer to the
and the other question to know if you
could proceed
representative long has a question
thank you madam chair
um
you stated that uh you're you you are
involved in judge training when it comes
to the best interests of the child
yes okay and in those conversations in
those conversations is there a topic on
gender neutral
uh care for the child
the ability for
um you know a gender neutral care for
the child
so that is a great question no there is
not right now that is not something that
we incorporate into the trainings that
we have we are typically one small
aspect of larger trainings that they
interact with so given the
amount of time that we have to gather
all the judges together and have an
opportunity to train we don't get to a
breadth of topics that cover all of best
interests of children although ideally
that that would be wonderful so no
that's not currently in the training
that we provide
but it is something that I believe is
very important for the judges to be well
aware of because we are seeing a lot of
needs for that with our children today
and if I may just confirm what I thought
I heard also is
when you get calls uh with respect to
divorces uh you're you're seeing a
balance with men and women uh with
respect to custody we get calls from
both parents um and we do not have I'm
just in trying to look at some of them
quickly we do not have a larger amount
of fathers calling as we do mothers it's
it's quite equal and there is custody
going in both ways on those thank you
yes
thank you um I will I'm trying to pull
up the parental responsibility RSA which
guides charges there's about 13
enumerated ones and our statutes are due
instruct judges to be gender neutral
that there's no preference to give no
preference to either
um sex that doesn't mean that the judges
wouldn't look at who's had the
traditional responsibility of that or
who's able to look at that going forward
but and I will I will provide those I
think those are important and I will
send those out afterwards if I can't
pull them up now but so our statutes do
they say that that doesn't mean that you
know their protocols don't say that all
I don't have much more to share
um again our jurisdiction is quite
limited when taking a look at the courts
um so we did want to come here today and
be able to present what we do have for
you but also to make sure we could
clarify that aspect because there is a
misconception that we have the ability
to intervene in court cases that are
divorce parenting cases only that do not
have a dcyf component to them
thank you
anything else yes please thank you madam
chair any uh question for you Ms Sanchez
uh specifically you spoke of this I call
it alleged model Court committee and
that you both or maybe just one of you
attend
would that be correct one or both
um Melissa is new to the staff so she
will be attending in the near future but
up until this point I have attended or
other others within the office so the
previous associate child advocate would
also attend prior okay one follow-up
Madam chair uh then specific to your
statement of what the office of child
advocate does and a lot of it being that
you don't have oversight over the
various components that when folks come
to you then what is it that you bring to
the table
that we can utilize in changing the
parameters of operation
and we can get it done while we're young
on this
because it's a serious matters of
families being affected today
is if there's new rules or regulation
not regulations rules of performance in
the court do we need a consolidation as
referred to to have a one one family one
Court one judge
or
what have you learned if anything
from the model Court committee
from the model Court committee uh we we
talk often in the role of my office on
that medical model Court committee is to
ensure that when we're talking about
court improvements we're keeping the
children at the focus and at the center
of that when we're talking about
parenting and any form and so my role is
really to ensure that any new protocols
or procedures they may be looking at
have the children's best interest in
mind in in them we've also learned that
it's quite important to have children
involved in court proceedings whenever
possible so that's another aspect that
is not happening everywhere all the time
right now but is something that is
encouraged to happen is to have the
children be able to meet with judges and
understand what is happening what we
know is that children oftentimes are
left out of that process but they know
something is happening they know there
is some kind of Court proceeding or
there is some back and forth about what
their future holds and they need to have
more of a voice at that table
and Casas and jals are great and have
the opportunity to do that but there are
also times where it is better to be
heard from the child themselves and not
rely on an adult because we do
understand that although they have a
role to fulfill which is the best
interest of children
it is subjective because it is somebody
else reviewing what is in the best
interest of that child is not the child
speaking on behalf of themselves so that
has been one topic of discussion in that
Arena
um as well as what I had talked about
the the difficulties of these different
courts and interacting and understanding
that it adds a lot of complexities to
the family system and to ensuring that
all the information is getting to the
judges when parents are going to
different courts is all the information
carrying over accurately one final
uh relative to what the the previous uh
contributor Mr Savoy stated and that was
the and I say so-called because you just
changed the debating platform is who do
we hear from not the parents but from
the kids
and to achieve that the best interest of
the children do we need that to take
place in Rules of Evidence or in rules
of the Court
so it needs to incorporate it does of
course need to have the component of the
parent piece so in in that committee my
role specifically is a focus on the
children but there are others that come
to the table with a background in
um prosecutors for parents
um and as well as parents attorneys
coming to the table and it's really
important to have all aspects of that
coming together because my goal does
need to be focused on ensuring that
children's best interests is kept in
that regard but of course we have
parents rights that are important that
we need to respect in this state so
there's another entity that is at the
table to speak on that regard and that's
why we need a well-rounded Committee of
of folks that all engage in this work at
different levels to come together and
that that is what's happening right now
with that group one last one
thank you for your patience uh Trini
martial then uh basically thank you for
taking the job by the way
you're on the front lines on this is
what would do you have a recommendation
at this early point on what a
Rules of Evidence or rules of Court
change or recommendation from you could
help us as we change the parameters of
operation
going forward I think there are a lot of
entities that can speak to that
um their Rules of Evidence do not apply
in the Family Division
um the protocols that have been
discussed that are being discussed by
the model court is I think where most of
this would be found although as
representative Macbeth stated uh the
rsas around both the Family Division
private parenting cases and 169c the RSA
relating to abuse and neglect cases
first and foremost is best interest of
the children in both of those statutes
as far as taking evidence from children
I I think probably the judicial system
would want to address that within their
protocols I know some courts do speak to
children in Chambers take letters it's
really
depends on the judge so again I think
that's something the model Court
discusses as far as consistency amongst
all the courts how those Protocols are
written and then I know attorney Baker
was here last week I used to work for
her and
um how the new judges are trained to
make sure it's consistent because I
think that is a trend we also see is
just simply
because it's discretion of a judge is
going to depend on your judge so it does
feel like a lack of consistency I think
for people across the state thank you
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh do you have
data on uh judges that speak with
children
or receive letters you don't have that
we do not know
um but as as Melissa explained
we hear from certain course that this is
what they do so we don't have the exact
judges it will just be this court
operates in this way and we think that
this is
best practice and so how do we then
spread that that's more discussed in
that model the model committee meeting
in that way thank you representative
katab
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
are you aware could you just give an
example of any of the courts that are
allowing the children to speak just I
think it would be nice to know an
example of it and maybe be able to get
some information you know us as a
committee to see how it's working for
them
um you know how they've implemented to
know to make it you know not to be at
the discretion of the judge and not and
to be more uniform and consistent can
you just give us any example that you're
aware of any court that you know that
may currently be doing that just so we
may be able to you know gather some
information from them on how they're
doing it
I don't have any specifics of the exact
courts that are doing it I would send
that question back to the judicial
committee I believe that they would have
a better understanding of it
um often I lead leave the specifics of
what court is doing what
um to judge Ashley and rather focus on
with her whether it's effective or is
you may continue
that is all that I have you may finish
thank you for coming wonderful thank you
um Mr chair could I just ask
representative Macbeth to give us the
RSA to which
she referred that I think would
I gather would answer a number of the
questions that were raised today yes
Madam Vice chair you may ask her that
thank you
thank you so I did find it so it's um
RSA
461a6 the determining of parental rights
and responsibility best interest so then
um Roman number one lists the 13 or
whatever criteria and then when it gets
down to Roman number three this is the
the um
section that I'd refer to it's just a
sentence long if I may read it it says
in determining parental rights and
responsibilities under this section
including residential responsibility the
court shall not apply a preference for
one parent over the other because of the
sex of the child sex of the parent or
the financial resources of a parent
in what subsection is that that is Roman
numeral three three of 461 A6 yes okay
good thank you
you're welcome thank you
we have scheduled we have scheduled for
next week in terms of people coming
before us at 9 30 the New Hampshire Bar
Association and at 10 15 the New
Hampshire legal assistance people I
think if I'm correct
I am thank you representative McMahon
um just I want to ask uh Macbeth on that
on the section section three if you
could just read that one more time
two-way Claire wanted to ask a
clarification on that so thank you just
let me you want me to read that Roman
numeral three yeah okay
yes
in determining the rights and
responsibility under this section so I
remember I said section number one lists
those 13 criterias
um that the court or considerations so
in determining the parental rights and
responsibility under this section
including residential responsibility the
court shall not apply a preference for
one parent over the other because of the
sex of the child the sex of the parent
or the financial resources of a parent
okay and so you know what I wanted to
ask your guidance on this is
does that come under the quote judge's
discretion on whether to carry out that
that specific black leaded law
determination
so I could give you my interpretation of
it um but I think it'd be better if we
talk directly to
um you know the court but the statute
which we wrote this committee your
committee wrote it says
um the court shall not apply a
preference for one parent over the other
based on the sex of the child the sex of
the parents so to me that is pretty a
directive that they shall not do that so
usually that that that that that would
eliminate the discretion again but when
you go back up to those 13
um
criteria and I'm not going to read them
all but it's you know the relationship
that each parent has with a child then B
is the ability to the parent to ensure
the child receives clothing Medical Care
shelter the developmental needs of the
child the quality of the adjustment to
the school so you've got you know like
13 or 10 of those things that that are
subjective but as far as when the court
applies you know
just solidly I mean says it shall not
based on sex so but I think we should
talk to them
not um the chair recognizes Greg
Lombardo
good morning Mr Lombardo thank you for
yeah press press the
there you go all right
again uh I am Greg Lombardo I'm a
divorced father with two little kids
ages three and four my daughter's almost
five I've had 50 50 equal shared
parenting since the beginning of my
divorce
parenting plan established with a 223
equals shared parenting plan
however I am forced to pay full
guideline child support
I Supply the exact same for my children
as the mother does except health and
dental insurance which is compensated
for in the child support calculations so
right now I do kind of pay for half of
everything
um
the judge totally disregarded that I
have the exact equal burden of child
rearing as the mother does
or the fact that she supplies nothing
for the children when they are with me
50 of the time
the judge stating although parenting
schedule is a shared one it does not
reduce wife's fixed costs of child
rearing
the most recent uniform support order
has my income at one thousand one 168
dollars more than her income my child
support payment is
1144 dollars the net result has her
having one thousand one hundred twenty
dollars per month more income than me
the court also states that she needs
guideline child support to be able to
afford to provide the children with the
same or similar lifestyle as the husband
can provide
the court makes no notion or recognition
that inherently they have swapped our
income almost completely
now I cannot afford to supply the
children with the same or similar
lifestyle as the mother can provide
the court also failed to add the child
support amount into her income when
attempting to justify its decision
stating the net result of the above
modification is that the husband will
pay child support of
1144 and 433 dollars a month for daycare
for a total monthly payment of 1576.
after paying support in daycare he will
now have three thousand six hundred
twenty in monthly
income to pay his and
his and the children's expenses
wife will paid daycare of 433 a month
and thereafter will now have
3595 in monthly income to pay her and
the children's expenses
the equity of this result is obvious is
what it says
um
as you can see they never added what I
pay her back into her income so now she
does have more than me
using the Child Support guideline
worksheet that was used to figure my
payment
provides information that could be
easily used to make it better and more
justifiable child support payment
especially when having 50 50 equal
shared parenting
the worksheet breaks down our incomes
and expenses and creates both of us a
parental support obligation amount my
obligation is that 1144 and hers
obligation is at 785
and some change if you were to use a net
the difference way of figuring child
support would put me at a payment of 359
the net result would have me making
486 dollars per month more than her
4873 per month in her income after
receiving support at 4 387.
I believe that this income is a lot more
fair
leaving the higher earning parents still
earning slightly higher while still
paying a fair amount in child support
per month
and one thing that has been also brought
to my attention is how
um having these heavy child support
payments when you have a child's
children even close to 50 of the time
creates an environment where neither
parent wants to better themselves due to
not wanting to possibly pay more in
child support or receive Less in support
trapping families like mine into
essentially staying neutral when we
should be growing and bettering
ourselves for the benefit of our
children
having a sliding scale parenting
time versus support payment or net the
difference model to create the child
support payment would also both
would allow both parents to better
themselves without being penalized by
doing so
representative Alexander thank you thank
you Mr chair um thank you Mr Lombardo
um I'm I'm wondering specifically how
um
the court has to do this when you
disagree with the child support payments
what does the appeal process look like
can you tell me a little bit more about
that and have you seen any issues with
that appeal process
um I've after every I've
it's been going on for three years I've
been to the courts every chance I get
trying to fight this since it was
established early on
and no matter what I kind of say in my
appeal it just goes back to that like
that she still has the burden of child
rearing and I believe it's actually
states to
um that even having your child 50 of the
time does not
justify a deviation from child support
payments or full guideline child support
payments it's basically up to the judge
to
decide if if you qualify which my judge
representative Smith
I guess I'd like to ask the chair of
children and family it's my
understanding that it is the legislature
that in fact has worked very diligently
over the years to try to
um
come up with the right formula
for uh child support So if it's not
working
would that not be a problem for the
legislature rather than the judicial
branch we would first have to stipulate
that it is the legislature's
responsibility and I have the book here
and I'll go looking through it and if it
is not the legislature's responsibility
we go in One Direction here as a special
committee but if we discover it is our
responsibility then we can discuss that
for possible legislation
representative Macbeth
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm wondering if you
would be willing if you redacted your
names and the bank account numbers to
provide a copy of your financial
affidavit and the child support
worksheet because it's my understanding
that they're things like housing
expenses and other debts that are maybe
considered and also the existence of
other adults living in the household
that are contributing that do factor
into your child support calculations so
it would be helpful when we were
analyzing this what's what's Equitable
um if we could see really you know what
other factors might have gone into the
child support calculation yes I I have
some of them with me today I was
planning to hand in but I can also get
more what you're looking for
that would be helpful
um
it gives us all the more strength in
arguing
one thing or another when we have the
documents in our hand it's not that we
distrust people right it's it's it gives
us more oomph behind us thank you
representative long
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you Mr
Lombardo
um
we do have retained bills on this
subject matter so yeah there there may
be
some benefit there for you um with
respect to extra curricular activities
for the children I know they're still
young Maybe for One
does the mother
have you know like dance lessons or or
any lessons or what have you and and do
you have
extra things you do with the children
um right now
look being so young they don't like I
don't we kind of do stuff together like
my kids just started t-ball my daughter
last year played soccer and we just
split those costs 50 50.
dude so there's nothing in our parenting
plan that establishes what she's
supposed to be paying for with her
guideline child support so she has been
refusing to pay for or enrolled my kids
in anything unless I pay for half of it
up until recently where I'm taking her
back to court again now she's starting
to try to
like pay for things on her own and prove
that she's been using this money
you know towards the children when in
fact I have evidence you know stating
seeing no other questions thank you so
much for your testimony and we'll we'll
accept your documents and um please
understand that they become part of the
public record okay so if that part of it
is a problem what I have done in my
other committee before is I have read
over things to a test that what is
alleged is in fact on the document but
uh once it comes in it it's anybody can
look at it okay I'm just gonna read
through my stuff real quick and then
and just remember the ground rules here
we're looking at a slice of a case in
which there is an alleged
violation or problem or whatever so that
I'm uh
2009 I was called by the local police
department in my town saying there was a
restraining order
on me
okay I asked why
so you just can't go home there's one
been pulled
so automatically
your 14th Amendment due process for
every American in this country
is eliminated
the state
of the federal government can't do
anything until you have your due process
where you get to face your accuser in a
I showed up 10 days later after I filed
the petition was asked by our attorney
to tell the court about all the violence
emotional physical verbal that she
suffered over the years with me
her answer to the court was I'm trying
I raised my hand
pro se litigant
said your honor I've never harmed my
the judge said he'd give a decision by
noon time
I waited in the court all day they said
come back Monday
so I came back Monday and I was handed
a decision that it was a credible threat
to my own family
I do have the 9-1-1 call that was made
which is a matter of public record
while I'm pulling this up I just want to
let you know that the New Hampshire
Nothing Yet two days went by Saturday
went to a birthday why did we came back
it was a couple of bags in the hallway I
asked my wife what's this
he goes oh me and Kaylee are going to my
mother's
Jay
now my dogs aren't in the house
sorry it went a little too far this is
on a show I was on with Senator Kevin
Abode it's called speaker he asked me to
I'd like you to handle him in that one
call all right let's take a listen to
emergency
I'm having a good message to she and my
husband is not allowing me to leave with
my style
U.S 382-0730 I am
um
calls 9-1-1 but you don't need the
okay
and so what's your lesson today Thomas
Mccarthy
um
[Music]
what you got right now I am at the
bakery
foreign
no
yeah obviously there are no restraining
yes you've gone over here a lot of times
so could you wrap it up in about 30
okay well there's supposed to be one
judge for one case and one Court that's
the New Hampshire mandate I've had eight
different judges sign off two marital
Masters two gals
a visitation center that I was had to go
to see my daughter
after 10 months of not seeing my
daughter at all after she had a nervous
breakdown was on suicide watch because
all she kept asking everybody if she
wants a father in her life sir thank you
for your testimony and we appreciate it
to have anything you wish to hand us
any handouts or documents okay we've
given you well more than the normal five
minutes
and the chair now recognizes John Kelly
he has written testimony that he's going
good morning John Kelly conquered
a man goes to the toy store to buy a
birthday gift for his granddaughter
a sales lady brings him to the Barbies
and she says this is Barbie goes to the
beach this costs 29.95 and this is Bobby
Barbie goes to medical school
she costs 29.95
and this is Barbie gets a divorce she
costs five hundred dollars
why the difference oh this comes with
Ken's Carr and Ken's house and Ken's
401k
that joke spoke to me
because in my divorce court experience I
saw the courts divide families into
winners and losers and I was a loser
I also felt the sting of gender bias the
best legal advice I got was that I
should not expect to be treated fairly I
was the wrong gender
I was lucky my losses were mostly
Financial I lost my life savings I lost
my retirement
and I lost my faith in the courts
but I did not lose a child or my freedom
or my will to live as others have
how can the family courts earn public
confidence including mine
from my own experience as well as my
conversations with other people who have
been
affected by the family courts I have
four suggestions
the First Reform is to establish a
mechanism by which the public May test
the courts for gender bias perhaps
something as simple as tracking the
percentage of times a judge rules in
favor of male or female litigants and
making that information public as part
of a Job review
in addition the public needs an
independent board to investigate
complaints of judicial bias this should
not be judges judging their colleagues
it must be an independent body
another necessary reform for the courts
is to take perjury seriously
perjury is crime it should be treated as
a crime
closely related to the issue of perjured
testimony is the strategy of filing a
false report of domestic violence or
child abuse in order to gain the upper
hand in a divorce proceeding
this strategy is devastating not only
for the falsely accused but it also
undermines The credibility of real
victims
filing a false report should be treated
as a crime
and the falsely accused should be
entitled to damages
number three
under the current system parents fight
over children
this is bad for the courts bad for The
taxpayers Who fund the courts
bad for the parents and especially bad
for the children
the only ones who benefit are the
uh
a solution to this problem is for
legislators to pass a rebuttable
presumption of shared parenting
and then to ensure that the family
courts follow the law
a fourth problem is the Court's lack of
respect for prenuptial agreements
I lost my life savings because our
prenuptial agreement was not written
down
Mark Twain once said that an oral
contract is not worth the paper it's
written on
that's a funny line but it does not
solve the problem in New Hampshire oral
contracts especially contracts like mine
which were corroborated by uh years of
documentation and witness testimony
oral contracts are valid except for
prenuptial agreements
that must change
I have a suggestion divorce lawyers will
not like it but it is good for everyone
else we can make divorce less
adversarial and less profitable by
requiring a filed prenuptial agreement
as a condition for getting a marriage
license
this requirement means that couples will
negotiate while they have a Cooperative
relationship
before the courts have turned them into
adversaries
I I I I I mean that as a signal that I'm
[Laughter]
yes sir are you willing to take
questions oh yes please
representative long
thank you Mr chairman
thank you for your testimony uh what
what year did was your divorce uh 2003
2003 and
uh follow-up follow-up how long uh how
long was the process or are you still
involved well the process has felt like
it's been 20 years depending on how you
measure it but the um
the actual day in court was
in your final degree
I kept about five percent of my assets
and I when was that finalized uh uh
Mr chair um this has been very helpful I
would expect nothing less for my 10th
grade English teacher
um who taught me how to write a
paragraph
um
can you please send us all of this um in
like just written out because I wrote
down some of it but I I think there's
been some very valuable things said so
so you know further questions thank you
did I get the name right you did good
job yeah Jackie I've done that one
before and why Dole I took a stab at you
did well it's only six letters we did a
good job at Ellis Island
um
uh my name is Jacqueline wydola I live
in Newmarket New Hampshire I'm here on
behalf of my deceased sister who Mary
wydola who um and this was her
experience in the district court
um
this case arose from a domestic incident
on May 20th 2017 when the child in
question Benjamin van billiard was six
months old and had since that time been
living at home with his mother and
father Mary waidola and Benjamin I mean
Brian van billiard the purpose of this
letter is to bring to your attention the
evidence that was provided against Mary
that attorney Finney and Brian van
billiard knew to be false this false
evidence resulted in the honorable Judge
decision to Grant Brian van billiard a
no contact order between the child and
full parental custody of the child until
the next hearing
um
Mary had no representation at the time
as it was an ex parte motion and being
unaware of the process and just acting
in good faith about the restraining
order in place between her and Brian
attorney Finney and Brian knowingly
presented perjured testimony to during
the ex parte hearing with the intent of
discrediting her motion Brian and
attorney Finney succeeded in this and
Brian's objection to the ex parte
requesting a no contact order was
granted and Mary was and and he was also
Brian was also granted full custody of
Benjamin Until the family courts would
review the matter
I have some attachments of Ryan's
objection to the ex parte motion this is
dated June 9th at 11 49 meaning that
Mary filed her ex-arte motion of relief
before 11 49 on June 9th
on July 7 2017 the Court held the
hearing on the petitioner's emergency ex
parte motion it was during this hearing
that Brian van billiard and his Council
attorney
Catherine Finney I just want to make
sure her name is stated that Council
attorney Catherine Finney stated that
Mary y Dolla filed her ex parte motion
as a way to avoid having no visitation
rights in the no contact order
618-2017
dv00074 now this case number is not the
case number cited on the on the ex parte
motion that would be
um
that would be sorry
435 2017
cr795 so we go from a civil
a civil ex parte on on a domestic
violence to now we find ourselves in a
family court on July 7th as it regards
to
um the baby Benjamin van billiard who is
now seven months old and has had no
contact with his mother for 21 straight
days
um
so attorney Finney alleges that Mary
filed this ex parte motion as a way to
avoid having no visitation rights
pursuant to the no contact order that
had not existed at that time of Mary
filing the documentation I'm providing
shows this to be false and that Brian
and his counsel knowingly lied and took
advantage of the lack of reputation of
my sister on that day on the morning of
June 9 2017 I accompanied Mary to the
10th District division in Brentwood at
or around 10 o'clock and the purpose was
to file the ex parte against the
protective order 435 2017 cr795 this
request for Relief stated that Brian was
falsely interpreting the order of
protection to prevent contact between
the child Benjamin and Mary the mother
so that is
um
anyway so those are I've already
presented you so the request for the
relief stated that Brian was doing that
and that we would like to have a move up
our court date on on case number 435
2017 and that Mary would be able to
expose to the court that this protective
order between the parents was borrowing
was allowing him to borrow contact from
the child because
she could not hold him accountable she
could not contact him on this order of
protection it only States Brian van
billiard's name the additional
protective Parties number two number
three number four are filled in N A not
um I also have a current copy of that
where you can see Brian van billiard's
name is the only name that is that has
the protective order so nobody else is
Mary is barred from having contact with
so at that point that was the 21 days
later that Mary had not seen her child
we nobody in my family had seen my
newborn nephew the ex parte Mary filed
clearly states that it was this court
date what 435 and not court case 618 as
attorney Finney
misrepresented so at this time we were
on the courts I was there as a witness
the other order did not exist and Brian
had not yet filed it Brian arrived
afterwards while we were there he was
served his paper at 11 30 and shortly
after this
um he was then began the proceedings to
file the protective order between the
child and my sister so it is only
logical that his objection motioned had
to be after he was served whereby the
time stamp on the protective order
between the child and the mother is time
stamped at 2 17 pm on the same day so we
believe this should have been obvious to
attorney Finney we believe this should
have been obvious to the judge handling
the case that he has two different
protective orders filed on two different
days and that Mary whereby is not
violating the later existing
protective order that did not exist at
the time of her filing
for this reason I respectfully conclude
that attorney Catherine Finney
misrepresented the information to defame
my sister and impede Justice
um the I would like to just bring up
that you know RSA 641 is perjury we had
another person bringing that up and that
this was not this false material
statement was provided it was
inconsistent with what was actually
happened and it was plainly false it was
known to be false all of these
um just
illustrate that there was um and no lack
of there was no no oversight all of this
the judges and the lawyers now just made
this decision and because we went from a
civil case about domestic violence and
now we were in a family court the
judge's decision was law 30 seconds
so give us the points we're going to
consider because in this iteration of
the committee we're not looking at
specific names people to bring charges
against we are simply looking at
procedural issues so I suppose the
procedural issue that um your the dcyf
and that other parents have brought up
is that there is no oversight the first
parent that gets the restraining order
has the benefit of all the force of the
court I don't believe that that goes
male or female but I do believe that
females tend to get restraining orders
first and maybe we would look into that
that which you know who who's working
male and female with dcyf with these
organizations and who's winning the ones
that are playing ball or the ones that
have have a restraining order against
them that they're now appearing in court
trying to just play catch-up on not
being able to do that
um I do believe that this that
lawyers and the judges and they they are
able to work in concert with each other
um and just completely Overlook it
whereas the offense now became not
whether Brian was using a restraining
order to falsely do this but that Mary
was undermining and disrespecting the
courts when it was clearly the case did
not get the time it was not um I just
want to add one more one more point is
that she had what that the woman that
used to work for dcyf had mentioned that
the judges have access to all of these
cases they have different numbers they
were presented to him and he was he took
and he just ignored he did not he did
not review the information that was
given to him and he was intentionally
misled by a lawyer who was taking
advantage of nobody being able to hold
her accountable for perjury thank you
very much and do you have anything you
wish to give us paperwork for the record
because we've got your testimony
I have documentation of the letter and
all the attachments referenced in this
letter I also have all of the
transcripts of the Court hearings where
um that this was this was at six months
of that um this this court hearing went
on for maybe almost a year we'll accept
all of that stuff okay thank you
um one question yes representative catab
and you may put your mic back on now the
one in the witness table
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Miss
vaidola for taking my question I was
just wondering if you could just
in 20 seconds just kind of Briefly
summarize what was the overall outcome
of the case like what what ended up
uh are you asking on that court date
when we went for the ex parte
just overall what ended up happening
with custody with the child and your
sister is now deceased so I didn't know
if there was
um so my sister was deceased there by
the court just dissolved the case Brian
now has full custody of the child and
does and we are
um
we are estranged and because that was
his intent the entire time was to
estrange my family and my sister from
the life of the baby so um he was
successful in that and um he just
utilized the court to bully her so there
was there was really no there was
nothing else we could do after that
point
um yeah
seeing none thank you so much thank you
for your time
and we'll look forward to getting
whatever paperwork you want to give us
at some point
what's that
oh you can give it to the researcher
good morning board members thank you
um
I mean I have a list of of issues in my
case
that would occupy more than five minutes
so I'm just gonna give a brief synopsis
for you
um
my intent is to submit this
electronically after the fact after I
clean it up but I'll briefly go through
some of the issues
um I guess one of them one of the main
issues uh was failure of due process
in regards to a parenting plan my case
started in Hooksett
and initiated uh in 2018
uh temporary hearing was held in January
of 2019.
at that time of the temporary hearing
and the order which came out there was
no parenting plan uh at all it was about
a
paragraph or so stating
um
you know the the visitation it initiated
by me in 2018 by filing an ex parte
because I was not being allowed to see
my daughter
um
that lack of a parenting plan uh lasted
until
2020.
um at least three motions were filed uh
requesting the judge to
um put forth
or hold an expedite hearing to provide a
parenting plan that would allow for
vacation holidays and like
that was denied until the final hearings
which in total there were about six
final hearings before we got to that
point
throughout the matter there was
obviously issues as far as not providing
finding facts both in property division
in downward deviation of Child Support
um
alimony
that case got remanded to the Supreme
Court
in 2021
it got remanded back to Hooksett now
under a new judge because the original
judge was retiring during the first
portion of the hearings
she made that very clear to US during
the hearings
and said her time was limited so we
um unfortunately
on the reband the the Supreme Court
remanded that all property division be
um
reheard that did not happen
and so we are in a peel number two
um
some other issues that I guess are of
concern to me
and people have brought up the uh
problem with attorneys making false
statements the issue of perjury
um the opposing Council during the the
first uh
session of my hearings I was represented
by attorney
that attorney has since
um
had to step down
under investigation
I filed the complaint against that
attorney in 2020
which was denied
after
uh being very diligent with the attorney
discipline office I went through files
to see how many other complaints were
lodged and there were a total of eight
docketed complaints which again docketed
complaints are only those which rise to
the occasion per the uh
the attorney discipline office
when I finally was able to go review
files due to covid in 2021
I had found that that particular
attorney
was had another docketed complaint which
consisted of
providing
patent Services as without being a
licensed patent attorney
um the number of complaints against this
particular uh
lawyer
um we're extensive
and again Empower you along before the
clock runs out what is your point that
we should consider as a committee the
point is that the eternity discipline
office is run by the Supreme Court and
it is operated by
again uh
other lawyers there should be an
independent committee
to pursue the matters uh at hand
um so one other issue that came up and
I'll try to be brief is there was I was
ordered to pay child support through the
Bureau of child support after paying on
time for four years
after dealing with a child support
office they assumed or made a claim that
I had in a rearage which I did not
I had argued it and it appears that uh
the child support Bureau does not
provide documentation to the public
of how they calculated a rearage
and thus people are left in the dark not
knowing exactly
how to do that the judge in my matter
refused to calculate a rearage and
pushed it to the child support and there
were no findings
to prove why 30 seconds I should be
paying through the bureau so now my
paycheck is obviously attached
so there was a judge this doesn't count
against your minute so there was a
judgment made against you but there was
no proof or reason as to why it just was
it's got about another 20 seconds
so I in that matter you know again part
they're they're lack there's a lack of
findings which is consistent I think and
something that's an overwhelming scheme
that people are having to deal with
being forced to continue you know to
file an appeal and the process again
appeal is at least a year and you know
this just continues and continues and
drags out I think uh the main factor is
is that this this committee could form a
decision or uh I guess make a suggestion
that the format of orders are the same
throughout minus the narrative which
leaves more reason you know
individuality to the judges
there is no checklist item for making a
decision and these decisions are all
over the map talking a lot about history
of things but not necessarily hitting
anybody
no
seeing none thank you so much thank you
you've covered a lot of things very
succinctly do you have anything written
you want to give us I will submit this
electronically if that is fine that is
chair recognizes Nicholas Rinaldi he
said time needed to speak five minutes
yeah and you've given us a this is one
document not a lot of documents with
multiple copies so what I've provided
with you is um that's that's the status
of my case on everything that's been
filed okay good thank you now we can
start
and the reason why I did give you that
is because my entire case was botched
um okay so I'm gonna start off that
a judge acting without subject
manageristician is acting without just
judicial Authority cohens versus
Virginia 19 U.S six wheat
264 404
5 LED 2257 1821 the U.S Supreme Court in
I'm sorry I'm just going to spell it s
c h e u e r versus Rhodes 416 U.S
232 94 s c t
1683 1687 and 1974 stated that when a
state officer acts under the state law
violative of the Federal Constitution he
comes into conflict with the superior
authority of the Constitution and he is
in that case stripped of his official or
representative character in his subject
in his person to the consequences of his
individual conduct the state has no
power to impart to him any immunity for
from responsibility to the supreme
authority of the United States
okay so that would bring us into a
section 1983 that's when uh it provides
an individual the right to sue a state
government employees or other acting
under the color of state law
so my name again is Nicholas Rinaldi Mr
Rinaldi let me go back to the very
beginning uh this is you're you're
speaking to a judge acting my judge is
actually judge Garner who testified here
without subject matter jurisdiction
correct they lose subjectures they lose
their subject jurisdiction when they are
in the process of committing felonies
and violations of state and federal laws
I just read about this last night please
continue okay actually so I'll get to
the the short because I only have a
short amount of time well we need to be
looking for and the reason why we are
here because we are here is racketeering
influenced and corrupt organization Act
Rico
we have judges lawyers
government officials all acting under
the color of law you've heard it here
they are
let me see here
I think to help with what we're
receiving from you could you speak
specifically to how this is a violation
how in your particular instance there
was somebody presiding without
appropriate subject oh jurisdiction
briefly I mean yes so I'll just go over
my letter intent to sue okay so uh
Federal violations violation of 18 U.S
code deprivation rights under the color
of law
uh violation of the false claims ACT
people we have all these laws already in
place we're just not applying them the
judges are aware of it they know what's
going on they didn't go through six
years to college uh to be dummies
judge Garner was my job he's still my
judge and he's actually a very
intelligent man and he's the one that
corrected my case so I am sitting here
uh bearing witness that my case has been
corrected and I have full custody of my
children
zero child support but I had to go to go
through hell to get there and it was
basically because of one single attorney
Kurt devilder
um
we have in our court we have
violations of uh 42 U.S code
interference coercion intimidation
violation 18 U.S code of assault assault
is not a batter
assault is not a batter
my first day in court
was with judge Green Hall
I showed up at nine o'clock for a 9 30
appointment
the judge didn't show up until three
o'clock
I left
oh I know I've said that quite a few
times
that afternoon I had an appointment for
a 20 250 000 bid on a project that I had
lost because of the judge
and when I left the court that judge uh
told me he was gonna throw me in jail
because I brought it to his attention
that that was the lowest a person can go
after 15 minutes I don't care who you
are if you're not going to show up you
call and you cut everybody loose it's
that simple okay you've got about 30
seconds left so let's have a couple of
real specific things we can get so real
specifically I've been false imprisoned
I've been I've had my fourth amendment
Fifth Amendment 14th Amendment violated
uh and I passed a psychoval that I I did
not ever want to give to the state
because my personal information uh is my
personal information and
uh that shouldn't be shared and I am
under Ada Ada I have uh
Attention Deficit Hyperactive Disorder
with
explosive personality syndrome Mr
Rinaldi would you take questions from
the committee do we have any questions
to Mr Rinaldi
uh seeing none thank you so much we've
got a big document that somebody's going
to read this summer
to
put your mic back on please sir that
there is a summary of my case are you
submitting this to our records I'm
submitting that to your record and in
hopes that you guys would pull the whole
case because
I've had the ability to start from the
beginning and go through to the end and
receive my good custody and we're
working together as our co-parents
this is wonderful thank you sir
appreciate this somebody will would
divvying up all the work over the summer
and somebody's gonna have some fun with
which I recognizes Donald Gilbert's I'm
now working into the batch of we've seen
you before and uh we miss you
so here you are again we've got
everybody for the first time and the
remaining cards are the second chance
here and you have a different matter
thank you that that is correct uh so
obviously thank you uh Mr chairman uh
obviously last week you heard uh my
testimony and uh rebuttals of some of
the prior testimonies uh I am still
going to follow up with that with both
written and oral testimony pretty
specific laws that uh were violated and
I need clarification I was not prepared
to testify enough today and flag it when
you do as to the date so we don't
correct mix them up okay correct you may
begin thank you
uh so so today I'm here uh obviously to
continue this journey uh as noted last
week I have over 13 years of experience
in the Family Court uh my earlier years
uh we were there multiple times a week
um for different matters
um more recently uh luckily we've been
to only three uh about every three
months
um for different matters but currently
what is going on and I think part of
that is this committee's
oversight and some other things that are
going on in this state is over the last
six months
we have had significant delays of
process there is currently seven
outstanding motions uh from multiple
variations of
time frames over this last year or six
months starting with January the uh this
is a guardianship matter
um
the guardian had filed to remove the no
contact provision that the court imposed
uh one year prior without anybody's
request
um
it was for me to not contact the
guardian
um
we were not able to hear that because
the garnet item did not show up at the
February hearing so that was postponed
to March
during the march hearing
there was testimony that possibly dcyf
was going to be getting involved the
judge ordered that dcyf basically gets
pronounced dcyf is dragging their feet
at getting involved to say the least the
office the child advocate is actively
overseeing these matters the Ombudsman
office is actively overseeing these
matters and I do thank them for coming
and testifying today
um
so with that uh to back up a little bit
in January February somewhere around
that time I also filed a motion to
conjoin dcyf to the guardianship of this
child
unbeknownst I really did not want to
um but it was a necessity because of
what was going on
the court still has not heard any of
these motions we were scheduled for
March we heard that potentially dcyf was
stepping in to file a Chin's petition
and place this child into residential
custody dcyf has not done so the
guardian the guardian litem and myself
have asked for DC the court has asked
dcyf to step in and take possession of
this child
coming forward so we have some of these
motions that are still outstanding we're
waiting to hear them they were scheduled
for June uh
get a letter in the mail yesterday
stating that the court has now postponed
it yet again to now July
any reason given no reason
administrative ruling okay
um was the reason that was given the
court had decided to
maneuver that
um again there's been other motions
filed uh motion to indeed have a hearing
on the no contact provision that's
preventing things there's a motion to
have access back to the child's records
because Juvenile Justice is requesting
my involvement
in that Chin's position petition process
and they cannot go ahead and do so until
the judge orders that I'm allowed access
to his records again
um and again the the court is just
continually delaying that so that was
one of the prefaces that I wanted to
touch base on today
um
ultimately again falls back onto my
point of last week that dcyf really is
to blame
for these issues the judge has requested
dcyf step in dcyf is refusing to step in
for one reason or another I could give
you my reasonings the office of the
child Abbott could give you their
reasonings but that would be unfair at
this moment in time to do that
um
I will wrap that up there I will take
questions on that in one second unless
you would like me to answer questions
but I do have one other quick point that
I did want to make make the quick Point
sure thing so to follow up with
um child support and whatnot uh child
support has been issued for myself
pretty much the entire time regardless
of the child living with me full-time or
not and there's two children involved
here
um currently uh one child is under the
custody of the state I am ordered child
support to the state but the state does
not hold any representation from the
court that they are allowed to get
restitution for this uh they're the ones
that have been delaying
um these proceedings to you know whether
reunification or termination
um so that's one issue that child
support seemingly is just being granted
as we all know is a mandatory fifty
dollars a month regardless
so thank you
representative katab
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Gilbert for taking my question so
I'm a little bit confused here if you
could just give like a little bit of
background or are these your two
children that you're speaking of and
you're saying that
um one of your children the court has
ordered dcyf to take custody of and they
haven't is are these your your own
children you're speaking of so yeah so
the first matter that was notified last
week is one child we share this same
father same mother for both of these
children
um the child this week is under the
guardianship of his grandmother with
significant issues of allegations of
neglect and abuse going on the court
notated to dcyf and has reported to dcy
for their own concerns and the pleas
from all parties to have respite and
residential care for this child
and ultimately it lies on dcyf for not
providing that at request of myself the
representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um I wanted to clarify you mentioned I
believe that this delay in process that
you have the child advocate office
looking into it as well as the Ombudsman
and I want to know what is the Ombudsman
office that you're referring to and just
confirm that those two offices are
reviewing this matter of delay and
process thank you
so obviously the Ombudsman is the
Ombudsman of dcyf uh DHHS a budgetman
they work closely with the office of the
child advocate and obviously I can
attest that they are involved I met with
them last week I meet again with the
Ombudsman this week but obviously under
their statutory requirements they are
not allowed to acknowledge their
involvement but they are actively
involved they have been since the
beginning of this year when significant
critical incidents happened in that
listening to your testimony Mr Gilbert
I just know from the medical and
counseling office of which I'm part-time
CEO if one of our professionals
is late
it is the obligation of the
front desk Personnel to let everyone in
the waiting room know and know why
not just oh she can't be here well
obviously
but if she had a flat tire or there was
a medical emergency that she had to
attend to at the hospital or something
like that people sort of feel like
they're being treated with some respect
delays happen that would be correct and
so am I hearing if the court says we
can't hear it until July
one sentence of we are waiting on so and
so to do such and such
to me doesn't betray confidences Secrets
or lack professionalism it treats you
with respect and gives you a reason why
it's just not they've all gone fishing
um could be there's not enough judges
we're working on that but it something
am I speaking to your point earlier so
that would be correct and obviously as
noted uh there's a lot going on behind
the scenes
um as you can imagine
um we do have the preface that things
are moving for both matters
uh but the parties at B are not being
that there is those secrecies
um and we do feel that it's one in the
same uh we do feel that the court is not
being fully forthcoming we do feel that
the division is not being fully
forthcoming in both myself the office of
the child advocate and the Ombudsman are
fairly on the same path of we need to
open up these doors we need to stop the
secrecies we need to
be forthcoming well ultimately it's for
these children uh you know these
children need to know what's going on in
their lives so that they are not
adversely reacting to what is going on
in their lives
would it be fair to say running parallel
with this
if the judge asks the dcyf to do
something
and the dcyf has not done so
would it be legitimate for the judge to
ask why either we don't think this is
anything we should be involved with
which then says to the judge go find
somebody else who will
or we're overworked understaffed
underpaid and under loved which is true
for all of us
yeah
um
so that would be correct uh chairman
this is really a push question
that that is where my
Baseline of what my end testimony and
changes for this committee
ultimately lies with is we are seeing
dcyf
continually the judge is ordering
specific things and dcyf is
again those prior matters are dcy
proposed orders so DC wife is proposing
these orders for the court to order
we're seeing that dcyf is not following
the own orders that they propose
and that could be very legitimate
reasons why a reasonable person would
say yeah you got it right but let's know
them exactly thank you thank you if I
were and I'm using the subjunctive voice
for an English teacher a person with all
power I would make this different and
maybe we can make recommendations so
thank you so much thank you
yes uh sorry I'm sorry I didn't see your
hand earlier representative
representative McMahon yeah I didn't
have it up I was awaiting
completion of your intelligencia so uh
I'm going to take that as a compliment
thank you okay good
Mr Gilbert last meeting we had you
indicated you've gone through 15 gals
and what you proposed not proposed what
you got a decision on allegedly today
was um
relative to
the uh
you found a motion to conjoin DC wayf to
the custody of a child is that the fact
that we eliminate the G8 gal
participation
so it would de facto that gal it would
then most likely under the the
guidelines of 1.69 C it would then
represent either a casa worker or
another gal or we could go ahead and
appoint the child their own attorney
which is currently in the process we
have a motion in that first matter to
appoint an attorney that's been waiting
for determination since March
wait just one follow-up follow-up thank
you Mr chairman then and and in terms of
getting your guidance on what ultimately
the committee will consider for
real or proposed changes to rules of
operation
what would you see what do you have in
your mind and how to facilitate a more
expeditious process
if
if we're not getting like you indicated
just a few senses ago dcyf not
responding in a timely fashion
so again that's something I need to
finalize that testimony and written
documentation for you and that will be
coming so I would appreciate that time
to be able to answer that for you in a
more
uh knowledgeable fashion for you and
outside of dcyf what time would you
speculate that would take place
for the work you just said you were
going to do oh uh so I Was preparing
that for this week there was a lot of
issues that uh I I don't think I'm gonna
have it ready for next week I believe
the following week is Memorial Day
weekend is that correct
sure yes I I believe it is so so I I
would have to say that I would like to
get back to you that first week of June
uh the committee has notated that they
are preparing to possibly here in June
as well I I would like until that first
week of June we are planning on meeting
the 16th and the 23rd of this month
we've announced we're taking the day
after Memorial Day the day after
Memorial Day being the 30th off we so
far has said we're probably going to
meet June 6 uh 13 it looks like we're
trying to arrange a road trip the 20th
we might be meeting
so that hasn't been set yet but I'm
leaning that way and I'm waiting for
consensus to build
but we can always take written test
electronic testimony representative
catab that's exactly what I was going to
say just that you could always submit it
to us electronically you know instead of
coming back out if you're having
scheduling conflicts you could always
email it over to us
sure thing thank you I know it's more
just uh I'm a very busy person creating
a lot of meetings with a lot of
officials here in the state
um
so that being said I do think uh again
my timeline was a little off there so
two weeks out would be the 23rd I do
believe I could have that ready for this
committee for the 23rd we have 168 hours
in the week and two clerks so they each
work 82 hours a week on this committee
alone would you believe so they'll be
it'll happen
oh thank you anything else good
uh before we called uh the next witness
I want to thank a couple of you uh who
maybe you're still here who
um basically pulled your pink card
because you said you would not be ready
to give what we need in the format we're
receiving it and in the time framework
we're setting and you'd like instead to
testify next week when you can do that
so hip hip hooray thank you
now Mr Albrecht are you going to be
presenting a specific
slice for us to consider
according to how we've been doing it or
you've got another one because this is
and the the correct answer is yes sir I
am
uh respectfully Mr chair in light of
most of the prior testimony I've heard I
only wish to add two very short comments
that's why you asked for only four
minutes that was put in earlier before I
heard other people say everything I
already wanted to say so it's four or
fewer fewer
so uh I think Mr Kelly already said it
much better than I could so I won't
repeat it I think Miss vaidola also said
it much better than I could so I won't
repeat it the only thing I will repeat
is prosecute perjury because they both
said it and I think you need to hear it
to that I will also add only in light of
Mr Rinaldi's testimony I think there are
a lot of people here who have docket
summaries approaching the thickness of
his I don't know how many pages it is
who would yeah yeah we've got a lot of
those and we've got a lot of allegations
in those that multiple judicial officers
have botched it again allegations
and I think a lot of us would like to
know and this is a rhetorical question
in light of that how do we get
a judge Garner to step in and sort of
fix it the way Mr Rinaldi
that is a topic for us to discuss
exactly in the previous iteration of
this committee when it was redresses of
grievances it was pretty darn case
specific people specific with some
pretty tough recommendations that had
teeth in them we're doing it differently
as you know but that does not take away
the need and so that is something we
need to look at as a committee in my
opinion how do people who have a real
beef with somebody in the system
get Justice we've heard of a judicial
review committee we've heard of uh
suggestions for at least one other body
that's fair game for this Committee in
general
exactly thank you very much I would
strongly exhort you to do that and as
one final request for anyone watching on
YouTube could you please State for the
record the best way for them to submit
publicity agent this is really good yeah
how do we how do they do that
Clerks
so you can go right online and if you go
to the New Hampshire General Court
website and you pull up I'm going to do
this right while I'm talking to you to
make sure that I tell you the correct
thing if you go under committees and you
go under the house and then
understanding committees you'll find our
pull it up special committee on the
Family Court
on the Family Division of the Circuit
Court you will see us a button that says
email all committee members and if you
go ahead and select that
um it will open you up to emailing up
all of us and that will be the
circuit court at
ledge.state.nh.us and for those of you
who are keeping score at home say that
again
foreign
it will be
House
special committee on family div
Circuit Court
thank you very much nothing further from
me unless you want to give me a hard
time
representative Smith
it's tradition
thank you on please just say that I'm
not part of that tradition
um I'm not interested in giving anyone a
hard time I'm interested in defining a
problem and identifying Solutions
um as to your uh comments about perjury
that is certainly nothing that this
committee
will enter
committed that is not for us to decide
and you know that what I do want to know
from you because you've
spent a lot of time thinking about this
is what are your positive
recommendations to this committee about
how improvements can be made in the
Family Court one that I believe you have
talked about is transparency
one that you've alluded to is
accountability knowing
who is to be held Academy for what has
to happen
um
one that's been alluded to is the need
for consistent training
and
oversight of that training I mean these
are these are things that we
legitimately can recommend but you've
given it a lot of thought what else
do you see that we could recommend
either for to the court or that the
legislature take action on
I think first and foremost I would be
grateful if every member of this
committee
viewed the loss of a parent the ability
of someone to parent their child as a
sanction worse than imprisonment
and in many individual cases perhaps
that sanction is warranted
but
indeed it is a sanction in my opinion
worse than imprisonment
and in criminal cases by way of contrast
to family law cases if there are
allegations of wrongdoing and I would
refer you to article 14 or 15 and 15 of
the State Constitution criminal
defendants get to hear in no uncertain
terms very explicitly what it is that
they alleged to have done wrong
whereas in family law
I think you heard a lot of testimony
earlier today
where people feel that decisions were
made arbitrarily where even upon the
filing of emotion for clarification they
don't understand
but it is that they're even alleged to
have done
um
we may be going a little I could even
point you
to a specific statute or say 173b
uh Roman numerals six it says the
courtial state I
I can't read my own writing but to
paraphrase
uh at the request of an agreed party in
writing the reasons for its decision
I would allege with frequency that's not
happening
even when it's spelled out
uh in a motion for clarification
and so
I think we need to raise the standard
and have a presumption
of
uh 50 50 equal shared parenting again a
presumption
whereby if that's not happening
uh
one of the litigants should come up with
some very good reasons why
and then the judge has discretion but
I'm hearing that judges have far too
much discretion
children are being
sent out of state
all of these allegations are coming up
based on
the emotional demeanor
of someone in court
and you lose your children for that
raise the standard
if you're going to lose your children
make it Crystal Clear what somebody did
wrong and why they are subject to such
thank you so much and that's very
helpful well if I could if I could
follow up
um we I think all of us on the committee
understand that it is likely that in
close to half of the cases that the
family court hears in in these matters
um
well in close to all of the cases that
the family court hears in this matter
half of the people
are unhappy
um
we live in a society where we think of
things as wins and losses and we don't
quite understand the gray areas in
between
um
the cases that have come
before us are not cases that are coming
in in an appeal they're certainly not
cases which are being presented to us
with both sides
explaining their position nor should
they be because we are not a trial
we are not an appeal court we are a
legislative body
so what I'm trying to get from you
is what we can do in the legislature to
make sure that the court best meets the
need of all of our citizens and you've
given us
some examples it's not a question of us
recognizing the the seriousness of this
matter I think every one of us on this
committee
understood that before we agreed to be
on this committee that's not something
that we need to be convinced of
but where do we go from here
is what we're trying to figure out we
are not going to review your cases we're
not going to change the outcome what we
are looking at is the system itself are
there things that we can do we certainly
know we need more judges
we certainly know that we need
additional Revenue to pay for those
judges
we've had examples today of other
expenditures that might very well
improve the situation including the
opportunity to have social workers
involved in cases in a way that
differentiates themselves from gals or
guardians or Casa or any of the others
all that we've heard now what we need
we've certainly heard that training is
not
consistent and that oversight is not
consistent
that is something that this legislature
can clearly require
of the judicial branch without violating
the separation
but
it does us it doesn't bring us forward
the very serious concerns that you all
have because we understand that you have
real concerns
we need to know now what
and the now what isn't going to include
a reversal
of your of your court cases not through
us that would have to happen someplace
else
you are organizing so successfully
people who believe they have not been
treated fairly by the court
and you know I I see your emails I know
the people you've brought here and
you've been diligent about that
but
if we just rehash
the concerns
that might be good to have given you you
know an opportunity to rehash them but
it doesn't bring us forward
and when I I really hope from you
is a reflection on what
given all the concerns how can we make
the system better
I think a full answer to that question
for me might be best done in writing not
ad-libbed in front of this committee
that would be terrific
thank you very much for that and and
thank you for your for your concerns uh
but is one brief preview I would Echo
your sentiment
uh if we could get rid of the winners
and losers and have more winners and
winners
clear in convincing evidence
of abuse that would be a wonderful thing
I was to thank the vice chair for a
wonderful wonderful wrap-up at the end
of a long and busy day when you submit
paper
or Electronics to the committee it does
not automatically go into the committee
file
I have to vet it or I may ask my vice
chair to vet it and if it is something
that we believe should be in the
permanent file then it will be given the
clearance to the clerk to place it
accordingly that statement that I make
at the beginning of every week's
committee meeting says that we do not
have to put it in the file It ultimately
becomes my discretion to do so so you
send this you can send that to me you
can send that to all of us I'll look it
over if it is as promised you know it'll
go into that file
thank you very much
30 seconds representative long thank you
uh thank you Mr chairman yeah with
respect to winners and losers I was
never a winner or loser my child was and
and I I look for what the child wins or
loses not what a parent wins or loses
representative mcbash thank you I just
wanted to follow up I believe that you
cited a um the statute RSA 173 B Roman
numeral 6 when you were talking about
transparency of judges and what they
needed to provide in their orders yes
that 173b is actually a domestic
violence statute that is correct so
that's not what judges are Family Court
judges are determining child
um
paranormal responsibilities on was there
a different statute that you wanted to
cite in regard to that or
uh respectfully I believe judges are
making parental decisions all of the
time in the context of DV cases and it's
a huge problem and respectfully that
actually was the Statute I was referring
to because they don't explain why orders
are issued or extended adequately and it
Cycles right back to by way of contrast
in a criminal case people get to hear
exactly what they're alleged to have
okay thank you thank you and with that I
close the special